joining us right now to talk about
college football and the weekend that
is about to arrive with big ten football
as well
uh is our friend from the athletic as
well as
fox sports and his new book flip the
script
lessons i learned on the road to a
championship that is a book that he has
written with coach oh
uh the forward by the dwayne johnson put
that all together and you got yourself a
triumvirate bruce feldman back here on
the rich eisen show how are you bruce
i'm doing well rich good to be honest
good to be on with you big ten
season is upon us sir best team in the
big ten is in fact
the ohio state yes or no yeah
yeah i mean all signs are pointing to
that justin fields has got himself in
the best shape of his life
you know yeah they obviously have to
replace chase young and jk dobbins among
others but
i think they're the most complete team
and and we'll see how uh
you know how they handle what has been
obviously a very unusual and
turbulent off-season and um and
other games that you're looking forward
to seeing this weekend would be set the
stage for me if you don't mind
you know look i mean to me a lot of eyes
are going to be on the big tent it's the
debut weekend
you've already got some news rondelle
moore who's one of the most dynamic
players in the country
really terrific receiver at purdue he
had opted out
then he opted back in and now you know
we're told he's not expected to
he will not play this weekend for them
against iowa
so start with that i think you're going
to have
you know his coach jeff brom is not able
to coach in the game jeff rahm had
actually
tested positive for kogan now from my
sources there say he's feeling better
but
he's got to sit out this game on the
field
i'm very interested to see what your
alma mater is going to look like they
have an interesting game
tomorrow night with minnesota who's
really good
they had a really good year last year
and what i want to see most
uh i want to see what joe milton looks
like he's the new quarterback
people inside the program that i trust
think he has
a world of potential huge kid runs well
big arm has really taken a lot of steps
forward since he has
got recruited out of florida to come
there so they have some good
good young skill towns it's probably the
fastest group
uh of skill guys that michigan had in a
long time there
but again it's you know how consistent
can they be
they have to replace nikko collins who
is a terrific player for them and
you know i want to see is this team
ready to be a legit playoff contender or
just
you know are they just a good team and
nothing more than that
well i'm looking forward to seeing the
quarterback i'll tell you that because
it's the first one
that jim harbaugh is going to be
starting a season with
uh that he personally recruited out of
high school which is remarkable
as to how long obviously harbaugh's been
on the sideline there in michigan i'm
very excited to see joe milton what are
you what can you tell me about him
yeah i mean everything i've heard has
been people are really excited he
you know when mccaffrey ended up uh
transferring out
i was told that the quarterback race
wasn't even close
that joe milton won that battle going
away people are really excited about his
talent
now you know i know josh gaddis who's
the second year oc there has been really
really intrigued by him
from pretty much the moment he showed up
and the development he has had
he doesn't need to throw everything 100
miles per hour i think
he has he has kind of gotten more polish
and more comfort in this system
you know now certainly would have helped
to have nikko collins as the security
blankets have that big frame making
plays
but there is a lot of speed to work with
it's a deeper
running back group that they've had
there in a while as you know
they had some question marks coming into
last year in the run game
i think the biggest thing for them
really
is especially to get momentum so many
times this is not a knock on shea
patterson but they had a lot of
turnovers
you know turnovers you know costly
fumbles and different things like that
and it just seemed like save for that
notre dame blowout where they crushed
them
it felt like there was a lot of just
instability and it was it was a lot of
two steps forward
two steps back with them and
you know we'll see i mean to me you know
they've had some solid quarterbacks
certainly you know jake rudock came from
iowa
and and was solid but the biggest gap to
me
between them and the elite
teams right now is they haven't had
anybody really special at quarterback
now that's a big ass to put on joe
milton to say can joe milton be a top 10
caliber guy
but if he becomes a difference maker not
just with his arm but certainly in his
in his uh you know what he also brings
as a threat in the run game
i think that changes things for them
because they have
you look at what they have on the other
side of the ball you know with
hutchinson and quitty pay they have some
some you know special kind of athletes
in the defensive front they have some of
that on the back end
i just think it's really you know it's
the quarterback play has been
pretty average since jim harbaugh's been
there and it definitely wasn't average
when he was
when he left palo alto certainly when he
had andrew luck there and i think
if you're gonna if you're really going
to be a team
that makes a run at a playoff spot you
got to upgrade it there
bruce feldman here from the athletic and
fox sports uh
here on the rich eisen show and you know
you mentioning jeff brom
uh the purdue head coach at age 49
testing positive for coronavirus last
weekend
and not coaching this weekend the the
big ten
uh refused also to allow him to even
coach remotely in any way shape or form
and
we all know again that the big ten is
starting now uh
after saying they weren't going to start
at all this calendar year
and other conferences did including the
sec
uh with a coach um a lot more well-known
than jeff brown but also
15 years his senior uh testing positive
for coronavirus but then testing
negative three straight times
allowed to coach in nick saban also
to take his mask off and bark at
officials like he wasn't coveted
positive earlier in the week
uh is there is this something different
are the protocols different for
for these conferences or brahms still
testing positive
i'm wondering if this is uh the first
instance
even before the big tens playing of the
way conferences are treating this
virus well they're all different
everybody has different protocols some
conferences are only testing once a week
now the the big ten
they're going to test daily it's
basically six times a week
and they're doing antigen tests now even
what the sec
is different necessarily alabama was
testing more than
what the fcc was requiring and
in the case of nick saban what we're
told is
that he had a what appears to be a false
positive that's good and it was on a pcr
test which is which is considered the
more thorough test
and then in order to get cleared you
have to have
three successive uh negative pcr
tests which alabama said he had so he
was able to get cleared
now talking to some folks in the big ten
especially late last week and we
got mentioned this on our big noon
kickoff show
there is some concern about if you have
a player gets a false
positive and in the big ten we're
talking about antigen
those rapid tests so if you get a false
positive
the day the morning of a game what the
big ten is doing
is you would have they're going to have
a confirmatory pcr
test to determine okay was that a false
positive or not
but if it's happening on a say a
saturday morning
you probably would not get the results
back in time
to be cleared to be to test
out and you know i think that from my
understanding is the big ten just feels
like hey
you know you're better safe than sorry
on this now what's
what's also significant is the big ten
if a player tests positive
and has the confirmatory positive test
you're out 21 days now coaches are out
10 days
but the 21 day period is much lengthier
than
the other leagues are having as they're
kind of they're clinging to more of the
cdc guidelines whereas the big ten has
gone a step further with that
so we should get used to that because i
mean this is
there's no question that's going to be
happening right i mean there's no
and this virus has its own uh
its own path clearly and uh and it
chooses it chooses
uh whatever it chooses to do so that's
something that we need to get used to as
sports fans
uh prior to you know losing ourselves
that in the in this wonderful league
in conference and you know what i i look
i i
i don't mean to you know the sec does
what it does and
the acc does what it does and the big 12
does what it does and the big ten
obviously is doing what they're doing
it just calls into question again it's
like how do you put it all together i
mean how
how in the heck is this all going to be
put together and come with
four teams at the very end of the year
that um that is healthy and safe and
and and we all are ready to watch a
playoff you know i know this is the
largest question of all that there's no
governing body that that overlooks
everything but
uh you know i i i don't even i don't i
don't know how to feel
basically is what i'm saying as we're
getting set to well
look i know you cover all sports on the
show and look there was times where
in the world series now and there was
times in the baseball season you know
the marlins and it was the cardinals at
one point maybe there was another team
or two
that had really rocky moments because
unlike
the nba unlike the nhl unlike the wnba
there was no bubble
so one thing that has come up a little
bit
at least from my reporting with college
football is when teams go on the road
whether it's a cramped
visitor's locker room or team meals
there have been
some issues of maybe there was players
with a fought with a false negative
on those trips and it's spread and so
you know we see florida's been on
they've had a game postponed dan mullen
the head coach
has has tested positive recovery they
are on a pause
still as they're trying to get that
under control baylor
as now they're expected to come back and
play
after having game postponed they're
going to play texas this weekend
but they had they had a big outbreak
amongst their team well look at the team
it wasn't the suppliers it was coaches
and i think you know we're in uncharted
waters with this
right and i think you know whether you
want to use the expression of
threading the needle to try to get to
the finish line and hopefully
you know fingers crossed that yes
there's going to probably be some
positives but hope positive tests and
players
and coaches who get it but hopefully
do not get very sick from it i mean
greg byrne who's nick saban's a.d at
alabama
he tested positive and he in fact had it
and greg byrne
has talked about it was it was
rough you know it was extended you know
10 days of he didn't need
hospitalization or anything but
it was probably about a lengthy of a
sick period for him and
as obviously we've seen different people
handle it differently
as it affects them so hopefully
with the numbers as big as they are in
college football because we're talking
about
compared to baseball even the nfl the
rosters are smaller
there's not 130 nfl teams you do 130
college teams with 100 people on a
roster
big staffs and also in some of these
leagues they're not they're not testing
the way the nfl is maybe the big 10
is testing that level maybe the pac-12
is going to test that level but the sun
belt is not
so you just got to hope that look we're
dealing with not the coaches but
the players are younger and the
percentages
uh are that the the serious risk
seems to be very low so hopefully it
stays that way and
and you know the season can find its way
to
you know the playoff but anybody who's
telling you for sure
how this is going to work i think
they're they're kidding themselves
so bruce tell me about your book flip
the script lessons learned on the road
to a championship
um and obviously we know lsu is in the
news right now
as this book comes out uh well i give
you uh
a moment for that as well yeah i think
look i would arg make the case that no
coach
working in football right now at any
level has had more of a crazy
uh path to get to a championship than ed
ozeron has
i mean he was a guy who basically
he he learned under jimmy johnson and
learned how to evaluate and coach under
jimmy johnson at miami
and then his own life spirals out of
control he had
he had to you know confront uh a battle
with addiction
that he has now been a 20 years sober
but i think he learned a lot of lessons
from that battle that honestly he still
has to
wage and so from him getting fired at
ole miss after being a young head coach
in the sec
having to look inward to see the
mistakes he made that he can't blame
everybody else that
he needs to see that and then all of a
sudden he works for his buddy lane
kiffin at tennessee and
usc and then learns from all the
mistakes lane made
and i think he's continued to grow and
you know i think for nfl fans when you
see flip the script you'll
learn a ton about joe burrow and how
that relationship grew
and why you know why you're a bengals
fan why you should be excited about joe
burrow because there's some really
revealing
stuff about him and the kind of leader
and
guy he is and i think you know as
lsu comes out of this because basically
they've lost almost their entire
starting 22 to the nfl plus
uh joe brady who is a big part of their
offensive system
and dave iran to their defensive
coordinator so again
you have a guy who is very used to
having to do this juggling act to
rebuild because he's had to rebuild his
life
and rebuild his coaching career and now
he's got to rebuild a program after
having
arguably the greatest season in college
football history and now they've had to
you know kind of rebuild it in the
middle of a pandemic with all these
other things so
it's been interesting that the flip the
script model
is actually kind of really applicable
as lsu is in 2020 getting off to a rocky
start
and now they're going to play south
carolina tomorrow night without the guy
miles brennan the quarterback they
really have been counting on to try to
replace
joe burrow and now they're going to
start tj finley tomorrow night
who is a true freshman who i don't think
anybody expected to be
the guy at this point but that's you
know that's the reality and i think
you'll see a lot for people who you know
get a chance to look at flip the script
i think they'll see a lot of stuff that
correlates not just on the field but in
general beyond
football congrats on the book bruce
thanks for the call really appreciate it
uh hey one nugget for you just in case
you're you need any other nuggets in
some of your writing
do you know there's only one big ten
school that plays minnesota
wisconsin ohio state michigan state and
penn state there's only one schedule
are you aware of that just for a nugget
for you to put in your column or if you
need it for any other
uh any other articles that you're
writing
uh i'll file it in my back pocket yeah
so you don't need to know the answer
you're just you you already know it
right you don't need to know the answer
would this be the scarlet knights no not
the scarlet knights
not rutgers no no only one school
is so important enough that yeah let's
get them play
minnesota and wisconsin and penn state
and michigan state
and the ohio state um that would be was
that head coach kind of vocal about
coming back to play football um
i think so i think he might have written
a statement or two
or whatever so just i'm just throwing
that out there for you
put that put that one yeah good luck in
getting out of the gate and getting some
momentum against the start of that
schedule i know
i thank you bruce that's all i'm looking
for thank you you take care of yourself
thank you rick that's bruce feldman